welcome back everybody our la vegas now
expert eric palacios is back with a very
important reminder especially
during the holidays drunk driving
is illegal it's dangerous first and
foremost and there are consequences
there are especially during the holidays
the police are out in full force
people drink a little bit more so it's
important to be careful
and not to drink and drive definitely
and how
how do you know if you've had too much
to drink
well it's hard to say i get asked all
the time how many drinks will put me
over the limit
it depends on many factors uh your size
your weight
your metabolism so if you've had two or
less you're normally okay
if you're on your drink strength be
careful
and find another way home all right that
is a great reminder and our check
our checkpoints actually legal around
town people always ask that
another great question yes they they are
legal they have to
meet certain requirements be done in a
correct manner
but if done correctly they are legal and
you can be stopped at a checkpoint
now can someone be charged if they're
not actually driving though
another great question a lot of people
uh want to sleep it off in the car but
they'll get in the driver's seat
the ignition uh you can be charged with
the dui
if you're in possession or control of a
vehicle so it's
a good idea to be in the driver's seat
with the keys uh if you've had a few too
many
always find somewhere else to keep it
off or call a rideshare and get home
what if someone is charged with a dui
what happens some folks try to take care
of it on their own
that's never a good idea it's always a
great have an attorney take care of this
for you can help with it
from beginning to end and help to
eliminate or minimize the damage of a
dui
well that's why we have you eric so
thank you so much for that reminder very
important reminder during the holidays
and like you said
just take an uber or a lift or call a
friend
better to call uber than to call me the
next day
exactly thank you so much eric take care
you too for more information give eric
palacios and associates a call at
702-444-7770